scott there you go i believe we have
some news to tell everybody
mike will cut my hair again
that is a minuscule piece of news
compared to what is about to happen in
our lives
oh i'm very much in debt now yes because
we bought a house yeah and we're moving
we're moving and we're leaving silicon
valley
uh we're moving to sunny san diego
aka my hometown aka
where scott and i met and fell in love
in the city that we've been wanting to
go back to for a long long long time
we have about two weeks to pack
everything and get the hell on out of
here
our home that has been our home for the
entirety of our stay in
the bay area that we've lived in for
five years
but yeah we can kind of take our time
packing
which is good but we also have a lot to
pack because we haven't moved in five
years
what a crazy time to do all this but
we're very
very excited we're looking forward to
our new life in san diego
[Music]
hello kona and i live to you
not actually live because this will be
posted weeks later but we're about to
eat dinner and guess what we're gonna
have
ramen this is actually orangey ramen
which is a very famous ramen store here
in the bay area and we ordered
delivery because apparently you can do
that and it comes in a deconstructed way
so
everything comes in its own tupperware
and you cook your own noodles
which means that it's like super fresh
and super good the berry does have some
good ramen so we'll miss a little bit of
that but san diego also has some pretty
good ramen too so
it'll just be kind of different but they
definitely don't have orangey so we're
glad we could eat it before we leave
aren't we yes
[Music]
today is thursday aka
the movers are coming tomorrow today's
wednesday
oh today's wednesday today's wednesday
tomorrow is thursday movies are coming
tomorrow
friday we drive down we've made a lot of
progress
lots of boxes everywhere but then we
also have messes like these because
let's be real
oh yeah and our little plant corner aka
the stuff that's going to be left behind
this trip and we'll come back and get
you plant babies
afterwards in two weeks from now when we
come up and clean everything
it's thursday and everything is gone
except for
our air mattress the movers came here
earlier this morning
and cleaned everything up so quickly
they took everything
ah we thought it was gonna take six to
eight hours
but it ended up only taking three
everything is gone
so echoey in here scott echo echo
hey everything's good we're gonna go
with some lunch because we are so hungry
and then we're probably just gonna come
back clean up a little bit do laundry
but we drive down tomorrow
it's happening it's so empty
it's so white in here kona guess what
we're moving you guys are moving
they don't care it's moving day
car nights moving day it's moving day
today is friday june 12th
and it's around 10 30 a.m we just packed
the car
watered our plants that we're leaving
behind here
our little nursery because we're gonna
come back for them in two weeks because
we cannot fit them in the car
but we're about to embark on our
hopefully seven hour journey
not much longer hopefully down to san
diego to our new house
you excited for your new house are you
worried
that we're gonna leave you behind
because we packed everything and we're
worried that we're not gonna bring you
with us he always gets worried
his face is always worried don't worry
buddy you're coming with us
we're gonna live together in a new house
don't worry why are you so worried
heading out
oh hi kitty she's back there we drugged
her earlier so that
she would uh be a little calmer but i'm
not sure that it really worked to be
honest
i mean this hasn't kicked in yet maybe
maybe
we got gas we got our mcdonald's
we are now on the 101 making our way
down south which is not how the song
goes
but i wish it was because it would work
really well in this instance
we'll be back in two weeks to say our
final goodbyes but farewell
hey cutie
[Music]
we're here at our house we just got here
here we go welcome
home welcome home
kona this is your new home
kona this is your new home
hello it's uh saturday morning we spent
the night at the house
and now the movers are here and they're
bringing stuff in and it's feeling more
like a house now
they're doing the work
that's gonna take months to unpack
probably
we packed in two weeks with that we're
gonna take our time
happy sunday morning sunday oh my god i
just realized i still have i forgot to
buy
turnips oh no we are out doing
errands we're gonna go visit our
favorite coffee place in san diego
go to the bank and then also go to home
depot because we still don't have any
appliances in our house
and we tried going yesterday but we
didn't really
like luck out on anything it is a
gorgeous day
here in north county san diego we
already went on a
hour-long walk with kona it's
beautiful life is beautiful here
beautiful beautiful
we're looking at refrigerators and
dishwasher
and washer dryer because i don't have
any of that stuff in our house and until
then we're just gonna eat out
all the time
[Music]
we are done shopping at home depot we
got a
fridge and washer and dryer and they're
not coming for like 10 days
but at least we got one in the work now
we're just waiting outside
at a ramen place when i grew up around
here there was like
no ramen or japanese food so we'll see
my feet really hurt moving makes your
feet really hurt
right yes my back hurts i'm getting old
yeah my my feet and hips hurt i gotta
stretch it out or something
we're getting old we're not young like
we were before
who am i kidding i'm still in my 20s
though
happy happy monday everybody today was
like my first kind of like work day back
which has been kind of weird
because it's in this house and there's
still so
many boxes and trash and stuff to work
through and unpack
but i just kind of took it easy and did
a couple of things
now that it's kind of like late
afternoon i thought i would take a
little tea break
so for tea time today i thought i would
enjoy
this this is bok su who is also the
sponsor for today's video
booksu is a monthly subscription box
that includes
a bunch of different treats from all
over japan
they've also got like tea pairings
inside too and this is the first time
that i'm opening it and trying it out
i am so stoked for this because we just
moved to an area where
asian markets are not that close i'm
someone who stocks up
on japanese treats whenever i go back to
japan or whenever my parents come
to visit us in the states which is not
really possible right now especially
because of the pandemic i
really like having my afternoon tea with
japanese snacks and i'm really glad a
thing like this exists so i can still
have that
so let's see what's inside this thing is
packed full of stuff let's see what
we've got here we got kinako mochi
ooh we got uni i'm guessing this is like
rice crackers
mini shiroko sando i don't even know
what some of these are hokkaido
azuki so azuki from hokkaido red bean
yuzu sake candy
oh i love sabure yakoi dude this is
probably really good
and come on
dude there's so much stuff in here got
our good old gudetama
and mochi green tea stuff
yes this is amazing there's so much
stuff
i'm really happy to see some of these
things in here because some of them are
like my
favorite treats so i can't wait to dig
in so every month
the box is going to be filled with
different foods because there's going to
be a theme every month
the subscription to the box includes
free shipping and ships to over 40
countries all across the world
which if you think about like going to
japan and like hauling a bunch of snacks
over
this is just like being able to bring
some of the best parts of japan to you
because they're sponsoring the video
they have an offer code for you which
also helps support me running my channel
so you can get 10 off of your own
authentic japanese snack box
for a savings of up to 44. using my link
and the code in the description box down
below
remember to use my code and my link
because that helps support my channel
and i want to keep working with them
because i always want to have japanese
snacks in my house
bookshoe thank you for sponsoring
it actually is just like a red bean
sandwich
i'm a beauty youtuber it's not even
focusing it's not oh there it is look
[Music]
oh there it is did it work i don't know
yeah it tastes like osaka man oh it's
not
it's not it's from i can't read kanji it
has it in here
from ibaraki whoa
tkg it tastes like tkg soy sauce
oh my god it's no good
[Music]
you